[Music]
you know what I've noticed is it me or
does everyone here have kind of a crazy
name that seems like a very Chicago it's
a big nickname town yeah really go out
of their way you know generally a
nickname is your name truncated or maybe
there's a big flower on the end yeah
sure how I got Joe or maybe Joey but I
knew a guy here for about 12 years named
shorty bighead and that's how I knew him
I didn't know his net he was in my phone
for a decade a shorty big head right and
finally I asked a mutual friend of ours
I said what's shorty big heads real name
and he said Steve would possibly be the
point that's it's a lot of unnecessary
syllables yeah what was your nickname
when you were here did you have a
nickname [ __ ] fingers
I wouldn't okay I'll play why I don't
know yes I do
where to god I don't know I don't have
especially cranky looking digits I don't
I don't know I have no idea why people
called you [ __ ] fingers for no reason
that just seems unlikely to me it what
how could I make that up no I believe it
may called you that I just think at some
point someone had that I would have
asked yeah yeah yeah
shorty big head it made sense he was
short and he had a big head I understood
the origin of that right did you like
that nickname that you're who gave you
the nickname maybe that's a clue a
bartender named bouche I don't know now
I understand you were just in is this
right you were in Washington DC for the
White House correspondent isn't a good
time there I mean that's a very
different town than Chicago why is it
fascinating I'd never been a DC and it's
really intimidating or at least it was
for me you just you're constantly
running into monuments for events that
you're not familiar with or statues of
people you've never heard of and you
know I know you know ok Lincoln Memorial
freed the slaves he's on the penny Oh
got it
you know Washington first president
wouldn't teeth cool but then you know
you run into like Chester a Arthur I
should probably know stuff I'm just
thinking you know Chester Arthur was a
president yeah he I've Wikipedian him
now when I got home
and that's ruined everything you just
walk around Washington and I got a
Wikipedia this guy well Jeff find out
what that's all about oh if he's on
money I know it if you oh you know
people on money yeah yeah I'm pretty
much that yeah they didn't put Chester a
Arthur on Mon oh they did